este hospital recibe cada día a más de
500 pacientes de toda la provincia de
Par One en el ala femenina hay cientos
de mujeres esperando los varones que las
acompañan desde un largo trayecto como
exige el régimen talibán aguardan a un
lado
me duelen mucho los riñones he venido
aquí con uno de mis hijos y mi madre que
tiene problemas oculares no tenemos
dinero tuve que suplicar a un taxista
que nos trajera y pagamos 20 afganis por
cada persona para sentarnos en el
maletero llegamos aquí y ni siquiera
tienen analgésicos estoy sufriendo mucho
y no sé qué hacer
ninguna mujer afgana estudia medicina a
las niñas se les niega la educación
secundaria y superior en este
departamento de ginecología escaso de
personal se teme lo peor para el futuro
otras secreciones
sí pero muy poca
[Música]
también le duele el abdomen
Sí es bastante fuerte
en el servicio de ginecología solo
tenemos una jefa médica el futuro parece
sombrío los hombres nunca dejarán que
las mujeres vean a médicos hombres cada
vez más mujeres tendrán que dar a luz en
casa sin asistencia médica Incluso hoy
los hombres tienen dificultades para
llevar a sus esposas al hospital la tasa
de mortalidad materna será mayor
Afganistán ya tiene una de las tasas de
mortalidad materna más altas del mundo
con 638 muertes por cada 100.000
nacimientos las antiguas estudiantes de
Medicina como Leila están desesperadas
antes quería ser médico para ayudar a mi
pueblo ahora no sé qué hacer
no sé qué quieren hacer los talibanes
con nosotros
no sabemos si tienen algún plan para las
niñas y las mujeres
privadas de Educación excluidas del
mundo laboral salvo algunas excepciones
obligadas a ir acompañadas de un varón
cuando viajan las mujeres son más
vulnerables que nunca en Afganistán